Hamas who are they Hamas is a
Palestinian political movement with an
armed wing called the isodyne opossum
brigades the group was founded in 1987
during the first Palestinian Intifada or
uprising against Israel's occupation of
Palestinian land it gained local support
by establishing food banks and other
social services
Hamas beat rival party pepper from 2006
elections held across the occupied
Palestinian territories
a year later it took control of the Gaza
Strip after a deadly power struggle with
feta Hamas says it's fighting to regain
Palestinian land but it also advocates a
long-term ceasefire with Israel
[Music]